SANGER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
YOU KNOW, INTERESTING THOSE
COMMENTS AS FRED WAS POINTING
OUT AND WHAT WE HEARD FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN THIS MORNING.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FACT THAT HE
IS ADMITTING THESE LOSSES, WE
ALSO HAVE BEEN TALKING ALMOST
SINCE THE VERY START OF THIS --
OF THIS WAR, WHEN RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE, ABOUT THE LOW MORALE,
ABOUT THE POOR TRAINING AMONG
RUSSIAN TROOPS.
THEY ARE STILL CARRYING OUT
ORDERS.
IS THERE A POINT THAT YOU SEE
ANY OF THAT CHANGING?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION, ERICA,
AND, YOU KNOW, THE ESTIMATES
THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
BRITISH, FROM THE UNITED STATES,
SOME OUTSIDE GROUPS, IS THAT
RUSSIA HAS SUFFERED 200,000
CASUALTIES AND MAYBE UPWARDS OF
60,000 OF THOSE DEAD.
PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE, THAT'S
MORE DEAD THAN WE LOST IN THE
ENTIRE VIETNAM WAR.
IT'S MORE DEAD THAN -- OR MORE
CASUALTIES, I SHOULD SAY, THAN
THE RUSSIANS HAVE HAD IN ALL OF
THE CONFLICTS THEY HAVE BEEN IN
SINCE THE END OF WORLD WAR II
THAT WE KNOW OF OR THAT WE CAN
COUNT.
SO THIS HAS BEEN ENORMOUSLY
EXPENSIVE FOR HIM.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN HIM
DO NOW IS BOTH PLAY TO HIS BASE,
THE INTELLIGENCE SERVICES, THE
FSB HERE THAT, QUOTE, GUARDS THE
BORDER AND ALSO MANAGES TO DO A
LOT OF THE OPERATIONS AS HE SAID
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT'S
REALLY NOTABLE IS THAT IN THE
PAST FEW DAYS HE HAS TALKED
ABOUT A PROGRAM WITHIN THE WEST
TO DISMANTLE THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
NOW, THAT'S COMPLETELY FANCIFUL,
IT'S TOTAL DISINFORMATION, THERE
IS NO SUCH PLAN THAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND AND I THINK THAT
YOU'RE -- CNN, OUR CNN
COLLEAGUES HAVE FOUND, BUT IT
TELLS YOU THAT HE'S GOT TO GET A
VERY NATIONALIST OPERATION GOING
HERE TO MAKE THE CASE THAT THIS
IS ABOUT MORE THAN UKRAINE.
>> YEAH, IT SPEAKS TO A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF DESPERATION REALLY WHEN
YOU PUT IT IN THAT PERSPECTIVE.
I'M ALSO STRUCK BY PUTIN
RECENTLY ANNOUNCING THAT HE'S
SUSPENDING THE ONLY REMAINING
NUCLEAR ARMS TREATY BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THE U.S., THE NEW
START TREATY WHICH WOULD EXPIRE
IN 2026.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE U.S. SHOULD
BE PREPARING AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, I THINK WE'VE GOT TO
PREPARE WITH THE THOUGHT THAT
THERE WILL BE NO FOLLOW-ON
TREATY AND THE TREATY, AS YOU
SAID, EXPIRES IN FEBRUARY 2026,
WE HAVE THREE YEARS.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO IMAGINE,
ERICA, A NEGOTIATION WITH RUSSIA
ON A REPLACEMENT TREATY AND THE
WAY THE OLD TREATY WAS WRITTEN,
THERE'S NO MORE EXTENSION.
IT WAS A ONE FIVE-YEAR EXTENSION
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN DID IN HIS
FIRST FEW DAYS IN OFFICE.
GETTING TO THE NEW TREATY WOULD
BE DIFFICULT ENOUGH IF IT WAS
JUST WITH RUSSIA, BUT IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT CHINA IS
BUILDING UP ITS NUCLEAR FORCE
TOSS A POINT THAT THE TREATY TO
MAKE SENSE WOULD PROBABLY HAVE
TO INCLUDE THEM AS WELL, THOUGH
THERE ARE SOME WHO DISPUTE THAT
CASE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GO INTO IT
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE LIVING FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN FIVE DECADES WITH NO
NUCLEAR ARMS LIMITATIONS ON
RUSSIA AND THE UNITED STATES.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT WE NEED TO
GO OFF INTO AN IMMEDIATE ARMS
RACE?
NOT NECESSARILY.
I THINK WE PROBABLY HAVE PLENTY
TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO, BUT
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF PRESSURE
AND A LOT OF POLITICAL DEBATE IN
THE COMING PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
I SUSPECT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE NEED TO TRIGGER A NEW ARMS
RACE.
>> AND ALSO, AS YOU POINT OUT,
THAT IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF CHINA.
IF SOMETHING ELSE WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
I DO WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
THIS.
UKRAINE AS WE KNOW HAS CONTINUED
TO ASK FOR F 16s, I WAS STRUCK
BY COMMENTS YESTERDAY, THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE FOREIGN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE TELLING CNN
THEY COULD BE A REAL GAME
CHANGER IN HIS ESTIMATION IN
THIS WAR SAYING IT'S TIME FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION TO STOP
DRAGGING ITS FEET AND IT'S HIS
WORDS TO, QUOTE, ARM UKRAINE TO
THE FULLEST.
IS HE RIGHT?
>> WELL, THIS WAS A HUGE SOURCE
OF DEBATE AT THE MUNICH SECURITY
CONFERENCE, WHERE THERE WERE
ABOUT 50 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS OUT
IN MUNICH WEEKEND BEFORE LAST,
INCLUDING A GOOD NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS AND SOME DEMOCRATS
MAKING THIS ARGUMENT.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM, THE ISSUE
IS AN ESCALATION.
IF THE UKRAINIANS HAVE F 16s
THEY CAN REACH MOSCOW AND THAT
COULD EASILY BE USED AS AN
EXCUSE BY PUTIN TO ESCALATE, TO
MAKE MORE NUCLEAR THREATS AND SO
FORTH.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION'S ARGUMENT
IS RIGHT NOW AT THIS STAGE OF
THE WAR THERE IS NO NEED FOR THE
F-16s.
THE MIDDLE GROUND SINCE IT TAKES
A LONG TIME TO TRAIN UKRAINIAN
PILOTS TO FLY THE F-16, THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING LIKE IT,
WOULD BE TO START THEIR TRAINING
NOW AND MAKE THE DECISION LATER
BECAUSE IT WOULD TAKE A WHILE IN
ANY CASE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE